I hope you're ready for a goddamned
fight because the mainstream media is
questioning our conservative faith at
every turn look the problem with
American Christianity today is all about
worshipping Jesus as a god and ignoring
his inconveniently liberal teachings of
social justice a lot of people are
looking at the Republican Party that
seems like the moral values and
principles are completely out the window
locking and suppressing voting right is
a non-christian policy hating gay people
is a non-christian policy promoting guns
is a non-christian policy it's a night
man it's contrary to the gospel no a
nightmare is being back at my childhood
home but it's not my home because my
dad's there and he's a clown with a
knife and also Hillary as president the
Atlantic an elitist rag named after the
most liberal ocean notes note that six
years ago only 30 percent of
evangelicals said they'd support a
candidate who was immoral in his
personal life but fast forward to now 72
percent say they could the leftist he
then say this proves the right is losing
our religion this is completely unfair
we treasure the Bible as a weapon to use
against our opponents and now they think
they can use it against us Hey fear not
Jordan there is hope
praise be it's our very own God
translator Laura gray what do we say to
hellbound liberals who try to use the
Bible against us blasphemy these glyphs
don't know our Bible when they cite
scripture to score political points
they're talking about the globalist
Bible which is full of politically
correct parole leper propaganda and fake
good news yes
hashtag not my Bible exactly modern
Christianity has been baptised in the
fire of 2017 politics and has risen
again yes it has
it is all here in the alt Bible you've
heard of the Good Book well this is a
good or buck full of wisdom for living a
spiritual peaceful life and taking the
out of the Democrat somebody should
cross stitch that on a Billups how I did
Jordan okay and before the libs claim
it's sacrilege to change the Bible let
me assure you we kept all the good parts
like the Old Testament stuff with the
vengeful God who's down with child
marriage and does all those hilarious
pranks like when he tricks Abraham and
almost killing no no it was just a New
Testament that needed retooling because
let's face it
Jesus was a SOI boy at kale mail a guy
who probably kept his shirt on while
walking on water yeah yeah jesus wept
total baina so break it down for the
unbelievers how did the seventy-eight
percent of Alabama evangelicals who
still support judge Moore justify their
vote well Jordan those voters can find
solace in the book of Kellyanne 217 the
parable of the election year says judge
not lest we lose the election see now
here God is asking is people to choose
between an alleged sex offender and a
convicted Democrat easy choice in 2017
we care about winners not sinners that's
the gospel of the old righteous yes one
and that explains why Alabama churches
have put up signs like this they falsely
accused Jesus vote Roy Moore yes it's
all about believing just not with women
yep yep so what about the Republican tax
plan liberals say it's unchristian
because it hurts the poor and the sick
for that we looked at the prosperity
gospel in Koch brothers 115
god helps those who help themselves to a
brand new private jet it literally gets
you closer to God but we all know the
greatest story of all is that of our
Lord and Savior American Jesus a
populous job creator who's rich with the
ladies supports the Second Amendment and
isn't afraid to talk tough to the haters
who doubt him a messiah
trumpets America Jesus is drunk American
Jesus is Donald Trump and today he
spreads his gospel the old Bible had the
Sermon on the Mount the old Bible has
the tweets on the toilet behold and
American Jesus said and I quote every
time I speak of the haters and losers I
do so with great love and affection they
cannot help the fact that they were born
death amen amen
blessings to Laura gray the fight
continues
[Applause]
[Music]